i look at this and there's a lot of
different things which i notice
okay the first thing which kind of
confuses me
is that i see powers of three on this
side and i see powers of two
on that side that kind of raises my
eyebrow okay that's the first thing i
noticed
uh the second thing that you notice is
we'll have a look at the left hand side
and you can tell me this already because
certainly
you've looked at it maybe it's not that
obvious to you what's unusual about the
left-hand side of the expansion that's
there
what's unusual about it good it's only
got even powers right there's the two
and the four i think the question
actually gives you six there's the ten
and this one would be zero right
okay so then the question is okay if i
only have
even powers on this side how am i going
to either
just get the even powers or get all the
powers and get rid of the odd ones
okay so either of those would be the
same thing and i'm not entirely sure
how to do that for instance if i thought
about something like this here's an
example
if i saw this color
if i saw this right let me think
okay now how would i go about
getting this out well you know we're
used to things like this
like this expansion right and that's
fine
but to get something like this the x
it's a hard way to do it because you'll
get all of the um odd terms that we were
getting which we said are a problem
because we don't want them right
so one way you could do it is you could
think about this guy
okay i'll just put n there um can you
see that this would be a better
proposition
right can you see why that would be
better because you're going to get
well you can only get even powers of x
right when you do this expansion
you'll only get these but then there's a
problem you do get the right powers of x
i suppose you get the right powers
of three right but the issue will be can
anyone see it
what's gonna happen you're still gonna
get all of the odd coefficients
right the powers will be fine but you'll
get this uh well at the end
choose not and then n choose one you'll
get your x squared
right just one of this guy but then
you're kind of stuck
right okay so you've got these these
powers are nice but these don't match up
right
so you've got two problems there number
one that the odd
ncr terms are there the odd coefficients
are there and number two
they don't match up to the right numbers
look at that one and two two and four
these should be the same okay so what's
going on
what else can i do here well right let's
abandon this idea then
this is this is bad all right but let's
come back to something like this
now i've got one plus x right
what's the x in the actual um question
they've given us
it's three isn't it it's three uh it's
still gonna be a one out the front
that's what's going to give me just
it's there's no there's no flipping
around of the powers
but if i if i just do one plus three
to the power of now my last one's going
to be 10
right so that should be my power here
what will happen okay now again i'm
trying to grasp the straws here because
i don't know what the answer is i don't
know what approach to take
but if i do this then maybe something
you saw come out okay
so let's just write it out what are we
going to get uh instead of n's i've
defined n is 10. that's my power
okay so i'm going to get 10 naught 10
1 and there's that pesky on power that i
don't want but it's there
10 2
10 3 that'll do
and then i get to the end there's
actually a um
10 10 there right but if you guys know
that's one
okay just like just like it would be
here
now just like this right just like this
line here
this slide that we've produced is good
but it's got a problem right
it's good that it's got you know this
one's got the squares this one's got
squares too
but it's got all those problematic terms
in there
so then the approach you could take is
well how am i going to get rid of them
how will i get written um
here's this expansion what is this equal
to by the way because it's a bit awkward
to write one plus three
we wrote one plus three to get this
expansion but one plus three is just
four right which is 4 to the power of
10.
right and of course 4 is just 2
squared is it 2 squared so by index laws
this looks to be like 2 to the power of
20. okay
now again remember i'm still at the
point where i don't know anything again
right i don't know what approach i
should take
but this is suspicious this is
suspicious right
you tried something with the right hand
side didn't quite yield what you wanted
but when you follow the left-hand side
you're like why is this suspicious why
might i raise an eyebrow when i see that
that's that's useful right the very
first thing i noticed that there are
twos here and threes here it's like oh
wait i can get twos out of this right
even more suspicious you notice
like if you expand this guy okay so
this is all just my rough working trying
to try to work out what path do i take
if i expand that you get this
that's very very close right that is
very close to this
okay what's it off by
it's off by a factor of two isn't it
it's a
factor of two like if i if i multiplied
everything here by two
this would be two to twenty right you
can't just multiply by things though if
i multiply
i ought to divide i haven't changed that
that's still the right hand side that i
have over there
so that looks like this
okay now we're getting very close now
okay all i was doing over here is just
saying just kind of like
firing in random directions and hoping
to hit something okay
i hit this right and that was good right
i hit these guys
and that seems good okay now i've
arrived at this point right
now here is what i got here
but i've got it i'm adding something to
it
if i can add something to it then in
theory i should be able to get
to here right if i add something to this
in this shape
the question is what is it
now i wonder if the pieces are coming
together for you yet
um i i have where did i where did i get
this from
it's it's an expansion it's it's this
guy right
so logic could tell you that this this
here
would also be an expansion of some other
kind okay
so what expansion would produce this
think about the expansion that gave us
this
what expansion would give you this and
remember i want to add them together
now the funny thing is let me try and
put this together one more time okay
i've noticed
these guys are good right i've noticed
this is good kind of
i need to add something to this right
stay with me this is the crucial point i
need to add something to
this that will get rid of things
let me say that again i need to add
something to this
that will get rid of things
can anyone see it yet the only thing you
can add to something which will make it
smaller
is something negative right they're
gonna be some negatives
but i want specific negatives i want
these guys
i want these to be negative those are
the ones that i want to get rid of
right
what kind of expansion would have
every second term
being negative can you see it yet
all right if you can't see it yet that's
okay
let me try to unfold it this is the way
that i would actually set up my proof
okay i'm gonna start from the right hand
side
okay by the way the people who asked me
about this last week
right um you said to me oh how do i
approach this and universally almost
everyone started with the left-hand side
okay
now this is the analogy i gave to some
of you i didn't give to all you so
hopefully it will make sense right
i think the right-hand side is an easier
place to start from
okay because this is all
nice and tightly bound okay whereas this
is all just kind of a mess
right it's hard to go from a mess into
something which is all
nice and neat okay if i gave you a
question in my trig right it said
something like this
sine 3x is equal to and then you'd have
some garbage over here right after you
do all the expansion
okay clearly it will be easier to go
from this and then decompose
right use like sum of you know sine 2x
plus x or whatever you get triple angle
out
okay so that's why i'm starting from the
right hand side how shall i write it
well um i i want to get this here right
so i notice
that that is 2 to the 20 plus
2 to the 10. okay i've already got that
down okay
which is half of 2 to the 20 plus
sorry that wrong sorry 2 to the 19
and 9 and that's 2 to the
20 into the 10. is that ok yeah all
right
now the reason why this is useful to me
is because i have an expression
through my blind working out right that
would land me on 2 to the 20.
okay now for reasons that will become
clear in a second
even though i wrote it as one plus three
here because i was thinking in terms of
one plus
x i'm going to write it here as
let's do some bigger brackets not one
plus three but three plus one
okay so this is my 2 to the power of 20
my 4 to the power of 10 right so that's
what i'm writing is 3 plus 1 to the
power 2.
now what shall i add it to what shall i
add it to well remember what i wanted
was some kind of
other binomial expansion that will knock
out all of these terms
okay there isn't anything that will just
give you the odd terms
you have to get all of them but you can
get one that will just knock out
half of them right namely
this guy
okay there's there's my two to the power
of ten and you can see what this
negative will do we looked at expansions
like this
it makes this guy it makes this guy
alternate inside
okay once you see this
the rest of it just kind of falls apart
but the hard part
was arriving at this it was realizing
that this would be useful to us
okay so let's give this a go uh let's
see i'm gonna need some large brackets
here so
i'll do a i'll do a brace so now i'm
gonna do this
okay remember it's a show okay you gotta
show so i can't just go from here to
ta-da
magically he pops out right so what is
this well it's it's it's this guy
isn't it right uh let's see ten
naught
there you go okay
now you'll notice that i've written it
in the same form that i wrote here
even though i fit these around it's all
symmetrical so it won't matter
right okay now what am i adding it to
i'm adding it to
this very same series but
with this minus one these alternate
terms will be negative
like so
um this next one would be negative it'll
be three q so i'm gonna write minus
and then this last one is even so it's a
plus
and there ends my brace okay
now you see i deliberately i mean i
could have written it all on one line
but i've deliberately written it on two
so you can see the cancelling that
happens okay so i've got my half
out the front okay and i've got two of
these
two of these two of these two of all the
even ones which is just what i wanted
i might write one more to get the
because i've eliminated a
term so i want three to form a pattern
there you go and of course that half
what's the half going to do it's going
to eliminate all the doubles
that's all so you get your 10
knot your 10 2 as you expected
whoops sorry
and uh in the result they've given to us
they've just evaluated that 10 10
as one no
oh they also evaluated this one of
course it's symmetric me rub that off
there you go okay so you have a look
and it's wow it's a whole one two three
four five six lines
but it's it was hard to get this line i
think
this line is hard to see it's like a
it's like a trig identity proof right
where sometimes you just have to blindly
flail around a little bit until you see
enough insights we're like ha
now i can see how i can put this thing
together okay does that make sense
uh i suppose i should have said left
hand side
okay please go from one side to the
other so much clearer
as a way of setting it out and almost
certainly will actually be quicker
as well